[Musica]
pittsburgh
la città che ospita questo evento l'inps
street la strada in cui sta avvenendo
liberty street a invasa letteralmente da
migliaia di persone tra queste c'è un
uomo un ragazzo 18 anni
lui abita in quella strada ci abita ma
non sa cosa sta accadendo
e allora fa quello che fanno gli altri
guarda in alto il dito in alto lì c'è un
uomo sospeso a 10 metri d'altezza a
testa in giù completamente legato chi è
quell'uomo
come mai tutte quelle persone sono lì
per lui e soprattutto
perché può essere un esempio eccezionale
noi per capire come migliorarci e come
affrontare le nostre sfide così com'è
stato importante per me nella mia vita
sia personale che professionale
ma andiamo per ordine chi è quest'uomo è
quest'uomo è eric face un ungherese
emigrato alla fine dell'ottocento
giovanissimo negli stati uniti
probabilmente
voi non lo conoscete come eric face ma
sicuramente lo conoscete con il suo nome
d'arte perché lui è harry houdini
semplicemente il più grande illusionista
di tutti i tempi
e allora la domanda che possiamo porci a
questa come è possibile che le rese
emigrato giovanissimo povero nella
difficile vita americana di fine
ottocento tra l'altro non ha mai parlato
un ottimo inglese si è riuscito a
diventare il più grande illusionista di
tutti i tempi ea stravolgere le regole
di un settore bene nei prossimi dieci
minuti io condividerò con voi tre
preziosi segreti che ci vengono da
houdini e che sono stati per me molto
importanti e spero lo siano anche per
voi anche solo come stimolo per generare
innovazione per moltiplicare le
possibilità
e allora e allora trasferiamoci alla
fine dell'ottocento negli stati uniti i
maghi i grandi maghi quelli famosi si
contendono il successo in pochi teatri
perché sono pochi quelli che possono
contenere i loro grandi show quindi
pubblico poco teatri poi chiaramente ce
n'è di che competere ecco in questo
contesto ulivi era veramente
sider già sappiamo noi l'abbiamo appena
detto del sua difficoltà di vivere in
quel contesto tra l'altro veniva da una
gavetta
lunghissima eppure lui non c'è stato non
si è pianto addosso e ha capovolto la
visuale ecco il primo insegnamento che
ci arriva da houdini è esattamente
questo un contesto possiamo sempre
vederlo in maniera differente con occhi
diversi
cambiare prospettiva cosa fate houdini
ha portato la grande magia dai teatri
sulle strade lungo i fiumi e quando
questo accade cosa è qual è la
conseguenza normalmente la conseguenza è
che chiede il settore comincia con i
suoi sì però si pero non funzionasse
però la magia vera e nei teatri sì però
queste son cose che vanno bene per gli
spettacoli di terz'ordine lui ha
capovolto la visuale è andata avanti e
ha capovolto anche quel sì però lo ha
trasformato in un però si e ogni però si
ha fatto seguire un'azione ha portato la
magia fuori quando voi fate seguire
un'azione dal pero si salite di un
gradino la vostra visuale cambia e da
quel gradino che avete raggiunto la
prospettiva cambia ulteriormente ci sono
altri orizzonti da vedere e quindi pian
piano houdini ha innovato completamente
il settore o per 16 anni ho guidato una
struttura di consulenza prima l'ho
creata e poi guidata per 16 anni di
formazione e consulenza aziendale
piuttosto tradizionale ma la un certo
punto in poi mi accorgevo che dal
mercato arrivavano segnali diversi e la
mia epifania è stata ricordo ancora
stavo vedendo uno spettacolo di un
prestigiatore americano e si trovava in
una situazione molto simile a quella dei
formatori c'è aveva una platea davanti e
alle spalle c'era una parete piena di
fogli completamente piena di fogli come
un po capita oggi a molti formatori con
i loro post it
ma lui faceva una cosa diversa lui
sembra riusciva a sapere quale era
sempre il foglio giusto da prendere e
spostarlo senza mai dare le spalle al
pubblico
e
mentre i formatori noi vediamo lì con i
loro pennarelli a scrivere di spalle io
lo guardavo le dicevo cavolo ho davanti
il più grande e formatore del mondo
allora mi sono detto ma perché questa
cosa non provo a portarla dentro il mio
mondo è una piccola cosa e ovviamente
sono scattati subito i sì però sì però
appunto è una piccola cosa si però la
formazione la cosa importante sono i
contenuti vero ma quando voi alzate
rialzati in quel gradino e e portare
avanti quella prima azione da quel
gradino arrivano messaggi diversi
arrivano visuali diverse relazioni
diverse e che se ne accorge e che ti
contatta prima non ti contattava e
quindi pian piano questo è cambiato e
quindi questo è il primo il primo
segreto e capovolgere la visuale
cambiare prospettiva e capovolgere quel
sì o in un però sì ma houdini portò la
magia non solo sulle strade mandò a
sfidare con la sua magia le polizie di
mezzo mondo sfilare studiava scott e una
yard la polizia del kaiser in germania e
quando faceva questo quando faceva
questo lui non stava più facendo un
gioco di prestigio lui stava
interpretando il desiderio di milioni di
persone
perché in sostanza era una sfida
simbolica alle autorità
repressive governi repressivi di allora
era toccata un sentimento profondo del
suo uditorio e questa è un'altra cosa e
scavare quando siete in un settore
la domanda da porsi è chi sono io qual è
il mio compito come può interpretare
quel settore utile ha interpretato in
maniera unica quindi nel secondo
messaggio che ci arriva a scalare e
questa un po quello che è accaduto anche
a me e il cric c'è stato quando anziché
raccontarlo in termini di prodotto l'ho
cominciato a raccontare in termini di
valore e ho trovato tre parole che sono
la mia stella cometa non sempre ci si
riesce però ci si tende e sono
entusiasmare chiarire portare lontano
quando voi fate questo cambia il mondo
intorno a voi perché quel punto voi
cercate e coerenza rispetto a questi tre
elementi del mio caso e quindi non vanno
più che bene le cose che facevo prima
fin quando dite io sono un consulente fa
bene tutto
quando vite io mi oriento verso
l'entusiasmo il chiarire il portare
lontano allora rimodulate la vostra
proposta in questi termini non tutti i
collaboratori vanno bene non tutte le
partnership e vanno bene quindi secondo
e scavar
ma quelli fine ottocento erano anni
veramente fantastici erano anni di
innovazione una di queste il cinema
ora voi pensate i maghi già si facevano
concorrenza tra loro adesso gli arriva
anche il cinema quindi immaginate lo
stato d'animo houdini cosa fa
per rossi però si di vento star del
cinema di vento e attore addirittura
fondo una casa cinematografica che
c'entra con la magia questo poco se non
che lui durante la prima guerra mondiale
era in tournée in inghilterra i teatri
erano vuoti perché gli uomini ea fronte
non quelli dove si esibiva houdini
perché perché erano pieni di tt top né
andavano a vedere non ludini mago malù
di star del cinema ora mettiamoci una
serie strumentale su queste cose perché
vi do un altro elemento e poi facciamo
la sintesi di questo terzo punto perché
quelli erano anche gli anni del volo i
primi voli fratelli wright non hanno
volato fine ottocento cosa fa houdini
voglio imparare a pilotare gli aerei che
c'entra con la magia nulla anzi magari
qualcuno diceva houdini pensa alla magia
che li già cina in oro tante da
risolvere come problemi di concorrenti e
quant'altro
bene ma sapete chi è stato il primo uomo
a fare la trasvolata dell'australia da
costa a costa
houdini
in apparenza nulla a che fare con la
magia se non che ancora una volta c'è un
serio che quando la notizia arrivò negli
stati uniti il giornale americani
uscirono a caratteri cubitali con titoli
di questo tipo houdini vola
purini paula
pensate che vuol dire per un mago
sentirsi dire vola dai giornali il volo
è il sogno di ogni prestigiatore lui
senza far nulla rispetto al volo ha
avuto questo titolo nel frattempo i suoi
concorrenti in teatro facevano la
levitazione ma mai hanno avuto un titolo
come questo e allora qual è il messaggio
il messaggio è e stendetele i vostri
interessi più cose fate nella vita è più
queste ritornano indietro moltiplicate
come è successo ad esempio con il volo
con il cinema houdinì questa cosa nella
teoria della complessità si chiama
effetto matteo dal passo di san matteo a
chi sa sarà dato più cosa fate più
ritornano indietro quindi curate più
passioni e trovato un modo unico per
unirli cuore provi almeno un campo in
cui siete veramente bravi siete
competenti
altrimenti fate gli stravaganti tanto
per essere stravaganti houdini si aveva
tante passioni ma soprattutto lui era
cintura nera di magia la contaminazione
di campi diversi e stato fondamentale io
ho unito e mia attività principale con
la magia con la scrittura e altre cose
la cosa che ho poi ho scoperto facendo
questo è che mi ha meravigliato e mi ha
entusiasmato e che quando voi realizzate
questa fusione riuscita a prendere i
punti forti che avete su ogni passione e
lasciare in secondo ordine in seconda
via dei punti deboli perché è chiaro che
vuol dire io sono la mia attività è
cominciata come mago giovanissimo ma
ormai non sono più un mago un mago
professionista oramai è molto migliore
di me ovviamente ma quando la magia la
prendo e la porto nel mio mondo posso
prendere le cose nelle quali sono più
bravo la scrittura io ho scritto diversi
libri o pubblicati diversi non mi sento
uno scrittore ma quando la scrittura la
porto nel mio mondo allora la
prospettiva cambia e tutti i punti di
forza l'idea stupendo perché fate le
cose che vi piacciono nel modo migliore
ma utili appunto diciamo e soprattutto
un mago
una volta mi chiese un giornalista rino
ma come mai non riusciamo a scoprire
trucchi del mago io dissi ti risposi ma
era abbastanza scontata il mago degli
all'attenzione e quant'altro però c'è un
altro motivo il mago non permette al
pubblico di guardare insieme e oggi
invece la creatività è guardare insieme
perché nessuno di noi in una realtà
complessa è padrone del tutela di questa
complessità ha bisogno degli altri
ora tutto questo quel ragazzo non poteva
saperlo quel ragazzo di 18 anni che era
lì a liberty street quel giorno
eppure houdini spiegava il suo segreto
con il suo corpo ad ogni sua esibizione
ecco questa è la parte finale no ma
houdini cominciava imprigionato
catene capite di forza quello è il
respiro soffocato quando sei così non
crei la crescita è soffocata poi però
eccolo qui a testa in giù in questa
figura maniera plastica sono
rappresentate di tre messaggi di houdini
e a testa in giù quindi capovolgere poi
va in profondità e quindi lo scalare e
poi in ultimo le braccia distese
el'estensione
houdini con questa sua postura
pronti senza volerlo ma ogni volta
aspirava il suo credo che non è nel
trucco ma enel come viviamo ea questo
punto resta in effetti un ultimo segreto
da svelare cioè chi era quel ragazzo di
18 anni beh quel ragazzo era un
emigrante anche lui come houdini
soltanto che veniva era partito due anni
prima
dall'inghilterra da southampton a bordo
di questa nave che la philadelphia
l'altro qui c'è anche la registrazione
su ellis island del suo arrivo c'è il
suo nome
tutto qua c'è anche la liberty street e
gli ho detto che era partito
dall'inghilterra ma il suo nome era
giuseppe
era un italiano era venuto da un piccolo
paesino in realtà del centro italia in
provincia di rieti
quel paesino era si chiama concerviano
lui e giuseppe non era o no e quindi
ogni volta che io penso alle grandi
sfide alle sfide impossibili
beh allora non posso che pensare a quei
due migranti
nel novembre del 1916 lì al liberty
street a pittsburgh grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]